[Music]
you are a redhead
um yeah what's going on with that well
you know I just wanted I did it for the
show yeah yeah disappear I did it for
this appearance very nice
oh my god my mom was actually a redhead
oh really kid yeah and so she didn't I
really liked it I have like a nostalgic
feeling for it but she was like oh why
would you do that yourself what I know
she said that being a red yeah and are
the most erotic people in the world I
love it I feel I feel great yeah you'll
change it tomorrow you know
congratulations you got engaged
I did I did get engaged yes your cancer
is a tattoo artist every well-known
tattooer yeah he's he's incredible he's
really cool at first I was like I don't
know if I'm cool enough to be with this
person this is amazing but he he's
amazing he's got tattoos actually from
here down to his feet are they you know
intense tattoos I mean so people go for
these sort of flaming dragon with that
like cool
yeah becoming out of its nose no he
likes anything is like as silly as
possum like get a cool tattoo maybe he's
like oh what about like a like a grim
reaper with a hula skirt or like a
dolphin smoking a joint
you know like smoking hip joint awesome
I remember when we were on tour I don't
remember sandy but we were on tour and
one of the crew guys came up to me when
we were doing our tour and he had gotten
a new tattoo design cone and check this
out it was r2d2 holding a Corona
he's got while you're at Scotland like
you wonder like how is that gonna aged
80 years from now I know what he
actually has layers of them like he'll
do like tattoos upon tattoos like he's
really irreverent he has one on his on
his arm that says bros before hoes which
it's really dominant that's the Creed we
all fall bros before hoes I take a
Sharpie to it and I'm like Lake you cut
his arm in the night I know I did
okay what about is gonna get a tattoo of
your name
he actually yeah he he did nine days
into hanging out he got this huge Lake
tattoo on his back which says Lake it
says Lake yeah and obviously if it if it
doesn't work out or something he'll just
put an R and an S at the end of it and
like painting yeah he doesn't even watch
sports but he'll like get in the canoe
as long as you know what your plan is
your escape plan exactly do you yourself
have any tattoos I okay I have a really
lame small tattoo that I gave myself you
gave yourself attach it yeah wait that's
it's a - okay listen just a mole I know
okay right there let's just look at the
facts nope
but like wait I don't see anything it's
a if you lose that you squint your eyes
if you just squint your eyes you can see
that it's a cross of some sort do you
see it yeah barely are you even paying
attention
really I was looking at myself in the
monitor wait I did it you know like I
went to the art studio when I was in
boarding school and I got a little India
ink and a little thread and I kind of
hand I did a hand poke I now know that
word hand poked at - it's like prison
tattoos and it is a prison touch how old
were you at the time 14 you were giving
yourself Prison tattoos at 14 look at
sporting school you get bored yeah sure
and you'd knock over a liquor store I
was kind of a criminal no yeah um I gave
other people tattoos as well which I
feel a little badly about with their
permission or again while they were
sleeping with their permission and in
fact I've been why I walked down New
York City streets and been like oh my
god Diana's a cow do you still have a
moon on your she's like yes I do it's
still here it lasted so your friends are
bitter about this yeah I mean you know I
wasn't that great you kidding that's
beautiful when I first met Scott I was
like yeah I understand your business I
understand I had a small business you
know you were yeah it was illegal yeah